I was actually watching clips of your
trip to Guatemala that you evidently
kept a video blog as well of your trip
yes
I was like I watched this thing this
morning I was rushing to get to work I
go what the [__] did Robin learn over in
Guatemala one point Robin's in her hotel
room and she starts her video blog which
is you know very important to Chronicle
this legendary fact-finding Mission and
at one point she's talking and then she
goes oh [__] I'm not wearing my earrings
hold on
I uh
got up early this morning because I
can't get used to Mountain Time and set
my alarm clocks wrong so I'm up earlier
and that's a good thing because I
wouldn't be doing this had I awakened at
my uh
appointed time
I think right now as I look at myself
that I need earrings
so hold on
okay that's better I was way into the
Vlog I couldn't put it down and there
was one clip where you were looking at
foliage at a motel look at the foliage
what is this what facts am I finding it
some cockamey bird is making noise robin
goes I think it's an owl there's no way
this is an owl
yeah it's the daytime I know don't ask
what's going on it was some strange
noise you can see Lush vegetation this
is some kind of a courtyard you're like
that guy who got bitten by the stingray
it's very Lush it's an owl that makes
this incredible whooping sound
oh do you hear that don't know what that
is and that's the other thing with
Robin's blog she don't know what
anything is
this the clip where Robin reads Spanish
Dorothy you're not in Kansas anymore
habitations
[Laughter]
I was going to reach through and get a
hold of you
teach you a lesson
there was a lot of nonsense going on
gotta show you these now I'm thinking
okay now we're finally gonna learn
something cheers I got to show you these
watch this
those are my juicy sandals
what is this
now I want to show you something like
okay listen this is a different culture
I want to show you my squishy panties
and look there's Robin's uh juicy
sandals you'll actually feel you're
right there with Robin
and then Robin's talking about the big
event with the you know she can be there
with the U.S ambassador and you watch
her block she missed the whole goddamn
event right I couldn't get there I was
in the airport for two days
found out I missed a lot of really good
things yesterday
I couldn't believe what was going on
because I was hypnotized me I tell you
exception at the U.S ambassador's home
so
can't be made up and we're leaving
Antigua today and we're or Antigua today
I don't know the difference either which
is a really historical and wonderful
City and beautiful and we won't be
coming back so all I will get to see of
Antigua and its beauty is this hotel
that's what I learned I don't blame him
by the way like what facts are you
finding out there what's in the mini bar
I'm watching this thing I'm going
berserking one way to learn something
oh